with all the changes on the strip and
around town it is nice to hear about new
things
people can do locally and safely rocky
is live at the bellagio gallery of fine
art where there is always more to enjoy
hey rocky
hey jc i see what you did there always
more because
this exhibit here is called always more
collecting
in las vegas theresa you're the curator
of this beautiful exhibit
what what is the theme what does that
mean we really wanted to talk about
um las vegas and its history and how
great it is to have these artworks
in people's homes in the city and
actually be able to show them to the
public not only to our visitors but also
to
the local people of las vegas and be
able to share incredible
artworks um to the community and that's
what i love about this gallery is that
you know i've seen people walking in
casually dressed you always feel so
sophisticated in a fine art gallery but
it's for everybody yes absolutely we
always
really try to make our exhibitions
approachable
and a little something for everyone so
you can be an art novice or
you can be an art historian and still
gain something pleasurable about the
exhibition
uh-huh or you can come see a picasso
pablo picasso original this is huge
let's talk about this piece
yes this is a piece from the mgm resorts
collection
so we've borrowed from collectors in
town as well as works from our
collection
and the pablo picasso is usually in the
picasso restaurant so we were able to
have it here for a couple months
um in the gallery and this piece was
done
in the 1940s when pablo picasso was
living in paris
um during the nazi time so it was nazi
occupied paris
and i think it's a really beautiful um
there's an orange kind of light coming
through the window cast in the shadow
the colors are incredible and this is
just one picasso there is another and
we're going to show you that one in the
4pm coming up so stay tuned you guys
i'll send it back to you all right thank
you rocky we look forward to seeing more
art coming up in the four o'clock
newscast
all right bacon